La OTAN, la Organización del Tratado del
Atlántico Norte, la alianza militar más
importante del mundo acaba de cumplir 70 años. Lo ha hecho en medio de una la crisis políticas
y diplomáticas más importantes que ha sufrido
en toda su historia.
Hoy, aquí, en VisualPolitik, tú y yo, nos
marchamos a conocer un poquito mejor a la
OTAN. Vámonos.
“Queridos amigos, Bienvenidos a Rumania”.
Seguro que ahora os estáis preguntando, ¿Pero,
Alberto, qué diantres hacéis ahí?:
[Vale, esto es un croma, pero de verdad que
hemos estado allí]
Veréis, cómo en 2019 la OTAN está de aniversario,
nos hemos ido hasta Rumanía para conocer
mejor cómo funciona esta organización, hablar
con algunos responsables y presenciar en directo
varias maniobras de las tropas de la OTAN
que han tenido en ese país.
[No me digáis que no es la mejor manera de
celebrar su 70 cumpleaños.]
En concreto hemos asistido al ejercicio bianual
Vigorous Warriors, donde se simula un escenario
de activación del artículo 5, en el que
han participado este año más de 2.500 soldados
-el mayor hasta la fecha- donde las tropas
se entrenan para prepararse para la gestión
médica de heridos en un escenario de guerra.
(El día 4 de abril del año 1949 se firmó
el tratado del atlántico norte que dio lugar
a la OTAN, la alianza militar más importante
de todos los tiempos.
A lo largo de estos 70 años, la organización
ha cambiado mucho, pero sobre todo ha crecido.
Si en su origen estaba formada por 12 países,
Hoy la integran ni más ni menos que 29.
Estados Unidos, Canadá, Turquía y otros
26 estados europeos, entre ellos varios antiguos
miembros del Pacto de Varsovia, la extinta
alianza militar formada entre la Unión Soviética
y sus países satélites.)
[Entre ellos el país al que nos hemos desplazado,
Rumanía, miembro de la OTAN desde el año
2004.]
(En total son 29, pero pronto serán 30 tras
la inminente incorporación de Macedonia del
Norte.
Hablamos de una Alianza que representa a casi
1.000 millones de personas, la mitad del poder
económico del mundo y la mayor parte del
gasto militar.
Una organización con estructuras de mando
conjuntas y tropas que se entrenan juntas
para poder responder de forma coordinada a
una crisis.)
Un poder sin precedentes en toda la historia.
Y es que amigos, estos 29 países que forman
hoy la OTAN, acumulan juntos un gasto militar
ANUAL de más de 1 billón de dólares.( $). Es
decir, casi las tres quintas partes de todo
el gasto militar de todos los países del
mundo.
Sin embargo, un momento.
A pesar de acumular la mayor parte del gasto
militar del planeta, de ser más grande y
poderosa que nunca antes, la OTAN no atraviesa,
precisamente, por sus mejores momentos.
Es algo de lo que en VisualPolitik ya os hemos
hablado en varios ocasiones.
Pues bien, en este y en un siguiente vídeo
vamos a ver con detalle qué está ocurriendo
y cómo ha ido evolucionando la OTAN con el
paso de los años, a qué amenazas se enfrenta
y cuál puede ser su futuro.
Lo vamos a ver, pero antes, antes veamos un
poquito de historia
(LA AMENAZA DEL EJÉRCITO ROJO)
La década de los 40 está a punto de llegar
a su final. Hace apenas cuatro años que la
Segunda Guerra Mundial ha terminado.
El mayor conflicto de todos los tiempos ha
dejado decenas de millones de personas que
fueron víctimas de la guerra, la enfermedad
y sobre todo de la brutalidad política de
ideologías totalitarias.
El final de la Segunda Guerra Mundial supuso,
sí, la derrota del nazismo, pero al mismo
tiempo también el surgimiento de una nueva
brecha que dividiría en dos, durante décadas,
no solo a Europa sino también al mundo.
Amigos, había comenzado la Guerra Fría.
En aquel momento Europa era un continente
devastado, económicamente hecho trizas y
con sus ejércitos desmovilizados.
(Pero existía una importante diferencia según
a qué lado de Europa mirásemos. Europa del
Este quedó bajo el control de la Unión Soviética
que mantuvo durante muchos años más de 5
millones de soldados en la región.
Frente a ello la presencia de tropas en el
continente de Estados Unidos y el Reino Unido
se estaban reduciendo muy rápido. Tan solo
entre 1945 y 1946 los contingentes desplegados
en la Europa continental por estos dos países
pasaron de 4,5 millones de soldados a menos
de 900.000.
A finales de los años 40 la diferencia en
favor de las tropas soviética era de de 5 a 1.)
Amigos, como veis, a finales de los años
40 la diferencia de fuerzas establecidas en
la Europa Continental era enorme.
Y lo que es aún peor peor, en aquel momento
el comunismo era una fuerza política en expansión…
en prácticamente todo el mundo.
Y desde luego Moscú tenía muy, pero que
muy claro que no iba a reducir su control
sobre Europa.
(Por ejemplo, en 1947 la república checoslovaca
aceptó el Plan Marshall... pero al poco tiempo
fue obligada a renunciar por la presión de
Moscú. Apenas un año más tarde en 1948
se producía un golpe de estado que dejaba
el país definitivamente bajo control comunista.
En ese mismo año de 1948 la Unión Soviética
llevó también a cabo el bloqueo de Berlín
Occidental, que durante meses tuvo que ser
abastecida mediante un gigantesco puente aéreo
con 900 vuelos diarios.)
En fin, amigos estas eran las circunstancias
que explican que en aquel momento en Europa
Occidental hubiera un miedo auténtico, real
a que las tropas soviéticas avanzaran hasta
ocupar nuevos países, como por ejemplo, la
República Federal Alemana, o incluso toda
la región.
Precisamente por este motivo, en 1948, Francia,
Reino Unido, Bélgica, Países Bajos y Luxemburgo
acordaron en el tratado de Bruselas una cláusula
de defensa mutua.
Pero, evidentemente, eso no era, en absoluto,
suficiente; así que rápidamente miraron
hacía los Estados Unidos: había que asegurar
la defensa de los países libres de Europa.
Y de esta forma es cómo, finalmente, el día
4 de abril del año 1949 , 12 países - Francia,
Reino Unido, Italia, Países Bajos, Bélgica,
Luxemburgo, Islandia, Noruega, Dinamarca,
Portugal, Canadá y los Estados Unidos - firmaron
el Tratado de Washington o Tratado del Atlántico
Norte que dio origen a la OTAN.
“El primer secretario general de la OTAN,
Lord Ismay, resumió el objetivo de la alianza
como “tener a Estados Unidos dentro, a la
unión soviética fuera y a Alemania debajo".
Kai Weiss, no leería el cargo.
Precisamente en este tratado fundacional donde
se establece el famoso artículo 5:
(“Las partes convienen que un ataque armado
contra una o más de ellas que tengan lugar
en Europa o América del Norte, será considerado
como un ataque dirigido contra todas las partes”.)
Es decir, este el acuerdo fue claro: todos
para uno y uno para todos.
“Esperamos crear un escudo contra agresiones
y el miedo a ser agredido, un baluarte que
nos permitirá continuar con el verdadero
propósito del gobierno y la sociedad; la
misión de lograr una vida más plena y feliz
para todos nuestros ciudadanos. Harry S. Truman,
Presidente de los Estados Unidos.
Continuemos. En el año 52 se sumaron a la
Alianza Turquía y Grecia y tres años más
tarde, en 1955 la República Federal Alemana.
Y fue entonces, ese mismo año, cuando la
Unión Soviética y los países de su órbita,
excepto Yugoslavia, crearon su propia alianza,
el Pacto de Varsovia;
Una alianza que aglutinaba todo el poder de
los países socialistas de europa:
Hablamos de más de 6 millones de soldados,
65.000 tanques, 15.000 aviones de combate,
2.000 buques de guerra y misiles nucleares
repartidos por los estados miembros.
Europa quedaba así dividida y enfrentada
por dos grandes alianzas militares.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto puede que
os estéis preguntando. ¿Qué ha supuesto
realmente la OTAN? ¿Cuántas misiones, cuántas
intervenciones ha liderado? ¿Cómo ha cambiado?
Atentos.
(EL AÑO DECISIVO)
Tras la caída del muro de Berlín y el derrumbe
de la Unión Soviética, la OTAN, una organización
que había nacional para hacer frente a la
amenaza soviética, no redujo su actividad;
todo lo contrario: poco a poco comenzó a
tener un papel mucho más activo, en Europa
y fuera de Europa.
En todo este proceso, 1999 fue un año clave.
Ese año tres nuevos países se sumaron a
la Alianza: Polonia, Hungría y la República
Checa.
Ni más ni menos que tres países que habían
pertenecido al Pacto de Varsovia y que por
tanto habían sido países enemigos durante
décadas.
(Fue el comienzo de un proceso que con el paso de
los años ha llevado a la OTAN a casi la mayoría
de los países de Europa del Este que formaban
parte del área de control soviética:
Letonia, Lituania, Estonia, Bulgaria, Rumanía…
incluso Albania.
Una enorme ampliación de la OTAN que ha enfurecido
mucho a la élite política rusa, pero que
a le ha dado a la organización más fuerza
además de contribuir decisivamente a que
los países de la antigua órbita soviética
que ahora pertenecen a la alianza pudieran
acelerar y consolidar sus reformas sin miedo
a sufrir represalias.)
Pero ahí amigos, no termina todo.
1999 fue también el año dónde la OTAN llevó
a cabo su primera gran ofensiva:
intervino en la antigua Yugoslavia para frenar
la limpieza étnica que el líder serbio,
Slobodan Milosevic, estaba llevando a cabo
contra la población albanokosovar.
Para frenar al gobierno serbio la OTAN llevó
a cabo duros ataques contra objetivos políticos
y militares.
Amigos, el espíritu de la OTAN
había cambiado, ya no se trataba sólo de una
Organización defensiva.
En un momento dado se llegó, incluso, a especular
con una posible invasión terrestre de Serbia
por parte de tropas de la OTAN.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Según se cuenta el entonces
líder ruso Boris Yeltsin, humillado, enfurecido
porque la OTAN se hubiera atrevido a incluir
en su Alianza a países Europa del Este amenazó
ni más ni menos que con la tercera guerra
mundial.
Si las tropas de la OTAN intentaban ocupar
Serbia, Rusia respondería.
("He advertido a la OTAN, a los norteamericanos
y a los alemanes de que no nos empujen a una
acción militar. En otro caso habrá con seguridad
una guerra europea y puede que mundial”.
Boris Yeltsin, Presidente de Rusia)
En cierto modo, años más tarde, en 2008
las amenazas de Moscú se convirtieron en
una realidad. El acercamiento de la Georgia
de Mijail Sahasvilli a la Unión Europea y
sobre todo a la OTAN condujo al gobierno ruso
a desencadenar una guerra contra este país.
Es algo de lo que, por cierto, os hablamos
en uno de nuestros primeros vídeos aquí
en VisualPolitik.
El caso, amigos, es que durante los últimos
años hemos visto una organización mucho
más activa.
Además de las continuas ampliaciones y de
la intervención en Serbia, la OTAN ha intervenido
también en Afganistán, en Irak y en Libia.
Y esto, es algo que ha generado una enorme
controversia:
Este es el debate hoy.
¿Tiene la OTAN que convertirse en una institución
que actúe allí donde sea necesario para
proteger a sus miembros, incluso si no son
directamente atacados?
¿Debe actuar en caso de que los derechos
humanos se estén violando de forma grave
en algún lugar del mundo?
¿O por contra debe limitarse a ser una Alianza
exclusivamente de defensa, es decir limitarse
a actuar en caso de que un país miembro sea
atacado militarmente?
Resumiendo: ¿Tiene hoy la OTAN futuro tal y como
está concebida?
Y, ojo, porque las implicaciones de este debate
son enormes.
Al fin y al cabo estamos hablando del futuro
y del papel de la Alianza militar más importante
de todos los tiempos.
(Hablamos de un debate que está en primera
línea y que en los últimos tiempos ha tenido
como protagonista indiscutible al mismísimo
Presidente de los Estados Unidos, Donald Trump…
que cree que la OTAN ya no sirve, no tiene
sentido, está obsoleta.
Y aquí es dónde, nos surge otra cuestión.
Hasta ahora la OTAN ha funcionado siempre
bajo el liderazgo de Estados Unidos, pero…
¿Podría funcionar y tener futuro si los
Estados Unidos abandonaran no la alianza pero
sí esa posición de liderazgo? ¿Es compatible
la OTAN con nueva estructura militar europea?)
De todo esto en cierto modo ya os hemos hablado
aquí en VisualPolitik en alguna que otra
ocasión, pero amigos en un próximo vídeo
lo vamos a ver con todo lujo de detalles.
De momento, amigos, lo que sí podemos decir,
más allá de los problemas y de los errores
que se hayan podido cometer, es que la OTAN
ha tenido un enorme éxito.
Me explico, hoy en Europa se vive en un entorno
de paz, seguridad y cooperación entre países.
Vamos, que somos algo así como una pandilla
de buenos amigos.
Y ojo, porque podemos cometer el error de
pensar que esto siempre fue así.
Nada más lejos de la realidad.
Durante siglos en Europa los conflictos y
las guerras entre países formaron parte de
la rutina, y desde luego, tras la segunda
guerra mundial se mascaba la tensión entre
el bando occidental y el bando soviético.
Y ahí la OTAN cumplió con su propósito
a la perfección, incluso aunque sus países
miembros no siempre se hayan llevado bien
y hayan tenido sus más y sus menos, como
cuando Francia se retiró de la estructura
militar conjunta - que no de la alianza - en
1966.
En fin amigos, esta es la historia de cómo
nació, creció y cambió la OTAN. En un próximo
vídeo vamos a ver qué significa hoy y a
que amenazas se enfrenta.
Así que ya sabes para no perdértelo suscribirte
al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.